this is the jocko underground podcast
number seven with echo charles and me
jocko willink good evening echo good
evening all right so recent conversation
that we had
recent conversation that we had and i
just wanted to address it because i
think there's some lessons learned so
i forget what triggered the conversation
but i ended up asking you
if i had ever
crossed the line
in my harassment of you now
there's actually some background behind
this
this is an off-air company this is an
awful lot that we're just talking and i
forget what brought it up
but
uh bozak john bozak when we were younger
and we were kids you know i mean i was
probably like 13 14 years old and he's a
couple years older than me so whatever
well he was 15 or 16.
and you know i mean
i kind of go hard in the paint right
and so i i'll never forget and it
actually left an impact on me
like i said something to him some insult
some some harassment to him
and he and he said in a playful but
slightly
meaningful way right we call that kraken
but falcon yes
he goes uh
you always go too far
and i remembered that was it's kind of a
it was a good life lesson even at a
young age to think okay i have a
tendency
there's a possibility that i'm going to
go too far so you and i was probably
harassing you the other day i was like
wait a second have i ever like crossed
the line
and you you actually said yes to there
was two occasions go ahead proceed let's
hear them
yeah so they weren't
the thing is
and i mentioned this as well where
this isn't necessarily quite the answer
to your question because because
technically you didn't cross the line it
was just more
it was outside of the whole dynamic i
think but then again maybe it wasn't
anyway this is what happened so we're
the first one
was
at the origin camp we're demonstrating
some jiu-jitsu moves
and
i don't i don't even remember exactly
why we're in this situation but i
had to
demonstrate the move on you
and then the you know when you
demonstrate a move right you do it to
till the other guy kind of taps for the
demonstration right yeah and by the way
it's even beyond that
let's say just a normal this is a normal
thing for you to expect
you do the move to me
you barely even put pressure i tap
everyone goes oh that's cool right it's
not a test of the technique exactly it's
a display of the technique
now that's what a normal good
friend slash training partner
slash demonstration partner would do be
like oh here's the guillotine you put on
once you know once you start to apply
the pressure they tap it i tap and it's
all good and now everyone goes and tries
it that's a normal thing to do what did
i do yeah and even i'll go and take you
go one further where you said oh that's
what a normal good partner or whatever
bro that's good bad partner that's the
protocol yeah that's the problem that's
what if you're showing a move
you go okay here it is here's what you
do and then the guy you like even give
him a little cue and then the guy taps
and then the guy taps
is part of the
demonstration part of the difference
it's not like oh yeah
so anyway we're talking guillotine and
whatever
jack was in one of his moods
and
so i do the guillotine and keep in mind
this is all like young guys so like the
young guys meaning early people white
belts you know yeah so if if there's
other black belts and you did that it
literally would be a different situation
true true so um
so
i do the guillotine and that's one of
those ones where you kind of gotta do
there's little details that you can't
necessarily see like if it was an arm
bar that i wasn't getting or something
like that it'd be like kind of obvious
you know but anyway so i'm doing the
guillotine and you're not doing the the
tap i'm not being the good
demonstration dummy yeah you're actually
being in battle
you're being the end straight up
antagonist
person
in life at this point in this situation
so and here's here's what made it bad
it's not like okay you do it i forget
because there was something like a
little bit more of a build up kind of
like this kind of this demonstration
this way was kind of required almost i
kind of remember something like that
anyway so i'm doing it and i'm doing it
harder and harder and you're just not
tapping but i could feel i could feel i
didn't have it like in like i wasn't you
weren't even letting me get it in for
the demonstration
so i'm like oh this guy so i'm like all
right well i'll just teach him i'll just
freaking muscle in and go hard and see
what up you know oh you want to play
like that yeah we go i had that thought
in my mind and i kept doing it and you
just kept defending kept defending kept
defending and then everyone's like
looking at me
which i can't see because i'm cause i'm
in the guillotine and at some point
probably when you said oh you want to
play like that cool i'm gonna go harder
and then i probably would oh you're
gonna go harder cool watch this
and i
you know it's i'm not easy to guillotine
we'll say that right great
who cares no no demonstrating no i know
but i'm saying like it's not like so you
had the move on me
but not only am i resisting i'm also
hard to guillotine yeah so i'm not gonna
win that that little beef i we just sort
of that materialized out of the
situation i'm not gonna win that yeah i
get it
that sucks either way
yeah everyone's looking at me kind of
like oh and there was some looks of
awkwardness kind of like oh this guy but
and whatever you know the awkwardness is
awkward it's not awkward whatever but
the thing that did bother me is like oh
you could have jammed up our credibility
here
with the moves you know kind of like oh
maybe echo kind of sucks you know he
can't even do the mood right so how did
you how did we how did this thing
resolve so obviously you squeeze and
then you go jackals and that's all yeah
and you're kind of like how this looked
in your face
kind of like you're so funny or whatever
and everyone's like kinda laughing or
whatever like it's funny and then
later on maybe even the next day or
maybe
yeah like the next day or next night
even you um in fred it was in front of
everyone now this is this was you know
when we all congregated this is the
additional item no no
this is how you kind of made up for it
essentially where um it was like a q a
situation where and this is not just a
white belt now this is everybody and um
and you're like i forget even the
question oh you were like they the one
the guy said how close were you to
tapping tacos guillotine that that day
you were demonstrating
and you were like oh i wasn't close he
was like you know what though he
uh i gotta admit i was doing stuff to
defend to defend the guillotine to mess
with him you know in front of so you
kind of explain what was going on which
was kinda saved it actually totally did
i have hands on your hands was i doing
that kind of defense because i don't
remember doing that no no there there's
just like little exercises yeah i
remember like you know when you say okay
echo do the guillotine on me you don't a
little i didn't oh yeah you're just like
chilling all down whatever i was like
where's this dean
you get dean in something yeah and he's
like
just not going to tap yeah and there's
nothing you can do about it yeah
all right so so so that's
that's one that's one time where you
felt i crossed the line
of and look this is a weird thing
because i
you know do you have an insult or do you
have harassment or do you have you know
sort of ribbing right that's the word
for like hey i'm just you know we're
just giving each other a hard time
that's the sub that's what i wanted to
talk about is
is is how do you handle insults right
how do you handle when someone's
insulting you and and actually
again there's this difference between
ribbing and fun and actual insults now
if someone's ribbing me for fun if
they're giving me a hard time on
something i'm totally cool i'll laugh
i'll you know i'll throw some ribbing
back at them
i
i realize that i have all kinds of
attributes that are real easy to make
fun of and i have i'm totally good with
it right like so i'm fine
i think that's good
you know and i think you know i mean i
hassle you all the time again not
harassment to the tune of like i'm
actually trying to
impose
my
you know uh
ego and personality on you and me okay i
don't do that right
and you
are
super chill and laugh at it and you know
you do you you have a good way of
taking
whatever ribbing comes your way and
utilizing it to carry on and you know
make a statement about it too so
so that's cool
but then when you start talking about
actual insults and here's the other
thing there's a
there's a line right with people yeah
and there's also you know you can you
how many times you've been seeing one of
those conversations where people are
harassing each other
and then you like see
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to
jockowunderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at jackonground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then
we will see you
mobilized
underground